[Music]
i got this email
that i i usually don't respond to these
but
this is one that i wanted to touch on
here here's what the email says
um
it's uh
this is condensed but it says i'd like
to know what depression is
this is from joshua says i'd like to
know what depression is
and he even put depression in quotation
marks
and then wrote is it real
he goes on to say from my experience i
see people that are what i would call
sad and they say they're depressed and
use it as a
crutch oh joshua so
um
yes
depression is very
very real
it's a physiological concept it's a
biochemical um
process in the human body
depression is very very real
um it runs on a spectrum some as the
compression of feelings the chemical and
spiritual stress from holding back
childhood
traumas or neglect
all the way to the deep dark black hole
the inability to move or function
psychosomatic functioning right body
pains etc
it's very very real
in some experience it in in some ways um
deeper if you will than others
um
the
the dsm which i'm not a fan of but it
does do some good descriptive stuff
basically
depression is
our is your body shutting you down in a
way that um inhibits
normal functioning right
um
depression lies to us it tells us that
things are always going to be this way
things are your fault and nothing you
can do will change your situation and so
over time your body just begins to
compress down stop
it can loop on people which makes you
feel helpless i can't even think about
this hopeless this is always going to
happen and then here's the bad one is
the burdensomeness
people would be better if i wasn't here
it begins to distort the way we see and
feel reality depression joshua is more
than just sadness
in response to struggles or setbacks
depression changes your perception in
the way you feel the way you see the
world and experience the world
bringing you feelings of emptiness and
doom it impacts the way you sleep the
way you work the way you eat the way you
enjoy life or don't enjoy life the way
you don't eat the way you don't work et
cetera
and
yes josh
i've met with countless people
especially when i was working in
university students would come say hey
my i just failed the test
and i needed to pass this test
i my mom just moved out on my dad
um
and they would say i'm just depressed
and i would say you're not depressed
you're sad you're really really sad
and then
in a month
two months three months they circle back
and they say hey i haven't eaten i've
lost 30 pounds
i can't breathe i'm unable to sleep
every moment i wake up i open my eyes i
start counting the minutes so i can
close them again
and moving my i feel like i'm doing life
with a weight vest on
that is an instant i need you to go see
a counselor i absolutely people say
anxiety's never killed anybody right
panic attacks never killed anybody he's
gonna ride those you gotta ride that
wave depression does kill people a lot
absolutely it does
so um depression looks different across
gender and across culture
um
a lot of men express depression by
pounding their chests and saying look at
me
it's called the one up position it's
just it's a physiological thing they
will they will sometimes bow up
um this is a a gender generalization but
women often show depression by one down
right
they
latch to the bottom of a family or
relationship and they put everybody's
needs ahead of their own and they just
ride out as slow as they can
underneath the water
and
both of those are expressing the same
powerlessness feeling there
sometimes it's stomach aches numbing out
um
back pains irritability frustration and
aggression especially in young kids
a great primer i'm going to point you to
andrew huberman's podcast the hubermann
lab podcast and you can scroll down and
find he's got an incredible biochemical
he gets way into
the neural chemicals and the the
neurotransmitters in the
neural modulator all stuff the chemical
process of depression it's about a two
hour podcast it's incredible if you want
to go down a rabbit hole but to answer
this question
broadly yes depression is very very real
and if you have found yourself in a
situation where
you are unable to function you do not
feel or express or see joy anymore
you are unable to laugh
your body doesn't respond in those you
just have a running low or more
importantly you feel like the world
would be better if you just weren't here
or you want you don't want to die you
just want the pain to stop
because i hurt
please call somebody
and joshua if you know somebody in that
situation friends say something
loved ones get in the middle of that and
say hey
you play a role here you got a purpose
here
i'm gonna call in everybody i can to
keep you alive and to help you heal
depression's for real
it's for real so thanks for the email
man
um
here
let me just uh
i had some notes there i was reading my
notes there about depression this is i
don't have these notes
let's don't get into the into the game
people to diagnose each other or to not
diagnose each other if somebody says
they're struggling and they're
struggling whether it's depression or
sadness who cares
somebody's hurting in your life
lean into that
do you just need to suck it up and move
on man
be wrong on that once and see what hap
what happens
it's not something to be wrong on lean
into them
and say hey
everybody
is helped by moving their body everybody
everybody's helped by having good close
relationships every everybody's helped
my sleep
everybody's helped by having someone
they can check in with and talk to
everybody's helped by eating well
right
those are all basic things that whether
someone's quote-unquote got sadness or
someone's quote-unquote got depressed so
dude josh don't play armchair
quarterback somebody says hey i'm really
depressed
say are you going to talk to anybody
about that
lean into that connection don't
disconnect and be like that's not what
that is don't be that guy don't be that
guy
or if somebody comes to you and says hey
i'm really sad because uh somebody i
love passed away or because me and my
wife aren't talking or
don't immediately jump like well it
sounds like you've got major depression
no don't do that either
sit with people
and if they need someone to talk to be
that encouraging voice and send them to
talk to somebody
all right that's my that's my thing i
just man armchair
armchair diagnose diagnostic
diagnosticians drive me crazy
armchair diagnosticians drive me crazy